President Trump will not be
attending this year's
White House
Correspondents Dinner because
-he's taking his ball
and going home. -(laughter)
He tweeting this weekend,
"Please wish everyone well
and have a great evening!"
Which is literally the nicest
thing he's ever tweeted.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Or thought or said.
The playful annual banquet
of politicians, journalists
and entertainers has been around
since before the days of
President Warren G. Harding
and Vice President
Nate Dogg Calhoun.
(laughter, applause & cheering)
Here they are in a file photo
about to regulate Wall Street.
(laughter)
Trump's decision is unusual,
but other presidents have
skipped the event in the past.
JFK in 1962
to protest the exclusion
of women from the press corps,
Reagan in 1981 following
an assassination attempt,
and Bush in 2003 'cause
he locked himself
in the Lincoln bathroom,
-and, uh...
-(laughter)
He's trying to get that door.
I love that tiling.
Comedians, Trump's made a habit
of disregarding
presidential traditions.
What's he going to flout next?
Slink.
I think this time
Trump is gonna defy tradition
by not lasting
the whole four years in office.
HARDWICK:
All right, yeah, points.
-It's very possible.
-(cheers and applause)
It's very possible.
Doug.
He's not gonna pardon
two turkeys.
-He's gonna eat
two turkeys alive. -(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right.
-SLINK JOHNSON: Ah!
Points. Jessimae.
I think he's gonna change
the lyrics
of "America the Beautiful" to
"America, the seven out of ten.
-Put some..."
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
There's more.
HARDWICK: Ah. "America,
the seven out of ten.
-I'd still stick it in, but,
you know." -PELUSO: Yeah.
-(laughter) -Put some fake tits
on her, make it nine out of ten.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, all right.
-I don't know why
-he's Italian
all of a sudden. -Hey.
-Hey! -Hey. -HARDWICK: Hey,
I'm-a President-a Trump
-over here.
-I know. I know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-BENSON: I like the tits yuge.
-Hey! -HARDWICK: Hey!
-Hey!
-Oh. -HARDWICK: Come on!
-(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Oh!
HARDWICK:
By the way,
our good friend
Anthony Atamanuik,
whose performed his incredible
Trump impression
on our show
on countless occasions,
has volunteered
to attend in POTUS's stead.
A lot of people
support the idea,
including Mark freaking Hamill,
so let's make this happen.
Tweet at @whca, use the hashtag
#MakeAnthonyTrumpAgain.
Let's see if we can get him
at the White House
-Correspondents Dinner.
-(cheers and applause)